- What the fuck are we doing today?
You're having me drink water?
(peppy music)
- Smells like hydrogen and oxygen.
- The consistency looks like water.
- It's like a metal-y,
bottle-y kind of taste to it.
- Tastes like water.
- Since it just makes me thirstier,
I'm gonna say it's expensive.
- And I think it's cheap.
- Will I drink this?
Yes, because it is the life source
that runs the planet.
- And this was Dasani.
- They charge you so much,
it is such a rip-off.
It's made by the biggest
soda company in the world.
There's something evil about that, right?
Like I'm not crazy?
- The way it splashes
really reminds me of water.
- I like this water.
- This just, it tastes like water,
which is what I want from my water.
- Expensive?
Like spa water?
- I bet this one's expensive,
now that I'm talking all
this good stuff about it.
This is Fiji.
- I love Arrowhead!
- This is what I'm talking about,
this is just the normal stuff.
Arrowhead, it's water, dummy.
Just drink it.
- What?
Is that water?
- I don't have any problems with it.
- This is like your
older brother's holding
your head underwater in a pool,
and you take just one little
gasp of air, desperately,
but all you get is chlorine.
- Oh, I don't like this one.
It's super filmy.
- Dumb expensive water that they
throw some PH shit in.
- Delish!
"Iceland pure spring water
"with a PH of 8.88."
- Added PH!
- Guys, my water palate
is pretty on point, right?
- So I know it's not cheap
because there's no metal aftertaste.
- Top of the taste, refreshing.
End of the taste, a little tap water-y.
- Fiji maybe?
- I don't know, something about it
tastes like it's seen some pipes.
- Cheap.
- You would still drink it,
but you'd have more fun
spraying it on your lawn.
- I would say like 1.50 a bottle?
- Ha, suck it Fiji!
- This is Fiji water?
- That's upsetting,
because it looks so pretty.
- Oh, this one looks fancy!
This one is fancy water!
- Oh my God,
I just know from the smell,
I don't even need to taste this thing.
- That's tap water.
- This is pool water,
a.k.a. Los Angeles tap water.
- Because everyone knows
L.A. water is disgusting.
- If somebody sells this,
they should be ashamed.
- I now want to go back and revise
all my other answers, because I was like,
"There's not a difference in water."
No, there's a difference.
This is not good water.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it's tap water.
- (laughs)
- No, you should not pay more for water.
If you're paying for this
designer brand bottle,
just know what you're paying for
is that fancy, cool looking design.
No one has any right to
be snobbish about water,
it's one of the most
essential things in the world,
we are lucky to have it,
just drink it.